las principales potencias de occidente
amplían sus esfuerzos Para apoyar a
Ucrania en esta oportunidad enviando
tanques de guerra el primero en hacer el
anuncio fue Alemania tras semanas de
insistencia por parte de canciller Olaf
shows se dio ante la presión y aprobó la
entrega de 14 tanques tipo leopardos
debemos dejar siempre muy claro que
estamos haciendo lo necesario y lo
posible para apoyar a Ucrania pero que
al mismo tiempo estamos evitando la
escalada en una guerra entre Rusia y la
otan y siempre vigilaremos el
cumplimiento de este principio
la medida de Berlín incluye el permiso a
terceros países para que puedan reportar
los vehículos una petición que en días
anteriores lideraba Polonia horas
después de Estados Unidos se sumó a la
iniciativa El presidente Joe biden
informó que entregará 31 tanques tipo M1
abrams y ratificó que Washington y
Europa se mantienen Unidos en su
objetivo de ayudar a Ucrania
de eso se trata ayudar a Ucrania a
defender y proteger la tierra Ucrania no
es una amenaza ofensiva para Rusia no
hay una amenaza ofensiva para Rusia si
las tropas rusas regresan a Rusia donde
pertenecen esta guerra terminaría hoy
quien llevaba semanas insistiendo en la
necesidad de que les fuera entregado
este tipo de armamento se refirió sobre
los anuncios en su cuenta de Twitter
Gracias presidente de Estados Unidos por
otra poderosa decisión de proporcionar
abrams a Ucrania agradecido con Estados
Unidos por el apoyo de Liderazgo es un
paso importante en el camino hacia la
victoria hoy el mundo libre está Unido
como nunca antes por un objetivo común
la liberación de Ucrania estamos
avanzando
Noruega fue otro de los países que
anunció su intención de entregar tanques
de fabricación alemana kiev sin embargo
aún no se ha especificado la cantidad
ahora el principal problema es el tiempo
en el que este tipo de armamento pesado
pueda entrar en funcionamiento en el
terreno tanto Alemania como Estados
Unidos hablan de varias semanas para que
esto suceda experto señalan que
solamente el entrenamiento de Las tropas
ucranianas en el manejo de los tanques
tipo leopard podrían tomar cerca de seis
semanas